the pandemic has made my work more
difficult because already 2 1 I had to
change departments I
usually work in rehabilitation and there I
am assigned to the department only in vacuum
the reorganization of work learning to
work with other staff members
that  'we are not
always used to the
heavy hygiene procedures to respect the stress and the
fear of this virus permanently my
expectation is to continue to do my
job in good conditions that
we are given the means  to work
properly because I like my
job I intend to continue
people can obviously help us
the population because we are all
links in a chain so to respect
the instructions to respect the
hygiene rules to continue to stay  home
and we will defeat
this virus I'm sure